the world economic forum is in full
swing as liberal Elites from all over
the world travel to the wealthy and
difficult to access Swiss mountain town
of Davos to hobnob enrich themselves and
conspire to control all of our lives and
if that doesn't sound cartoonishly
villainous enough the we Elites decided
to kick things up a notch this year by
inviting an actual witch to cast magic
spells on the
panelists
Elon Musk referred to this person in the
headdress with the face paint and
everything as Elizabeth Warren but she
looks a little
different this's obviously some sort of
prayer it's obviously not a Christian
prayer
so one can only imagine which uh
supposed deities she's invoking okay now
she's breathing on her hands that
doesn't seem very cautious with Co and
oh there we go she coughed on one of the
panelists
faces okay another one
just they're obviously just messing with
us because we led the charge of saying
wear face masks don't you can't ever
cough you can't breathe now she's just
coughing a mixture of
her uh presumably bacteria ridden breath
but also at the spiritual level
uh who knows what kind of um Spirits
it's weird the lady in question here
Styles herself an indigenous Shaman
which is just the PC term for witch and
it's nothing new for all of human
history prideful Elites have been
inclined toward the ridiculous occult
worship of false gods the indigenous
tribes all did it the Canaanites did it
even the Israelites did it when Moses
left them to their own devices for 5
minutes in the desert the counterparts
to shamans and witches are priests and
Prophets both groups dress in funny
clothing and perform rituals the
difference is that while shamans Cort
with demons prophets proclaim the truth
and therefore appear to predict the
future but as a wise priest once
observed they only predict the future in
the derivative sense of warning of the
consequences of denying the truth we
know the liberal Elites of we have
spread plenty of Lies
now they're dancing around with actual
witches it doesn't take an Old Testament
Prophet to know that the consequences
are unlikely to be good I'm Michael
nolles this is the Michael nlls
Show
welcome back to the show rup Paul has
some advice and we're listening for some
reason rup Paul says if a drag queen
wants to read you a story at a library
let her we will examine the wisdom of
that advice in just a moment first
though there is some good news coming
out of we we that's we is how the cool
guys pronounce
WF or World economic Forum we're going
to have some more stuff on we coming up
in a little bit but that's that's how
they all refer to it over there and it's
this insufferable group of big lib
Elites and crony corporate leaders and
apparently witches and they all conspire
in this really ritzy mountain town to
control the entire world and to subvert
self-government and to do a whole host
of nasty things which is why it was so
refreshing when the newly elected leader
of Argentina Javier mle showed up that
worried a lot of people they said oh no
mle the populist the libertarian he's is
going to become a w guy but he didn't
stick to the usual Davos
script today I'm
here to tell you that the Western world
is in
danger and it is endangered because
those who are supposed to have to defend
the values of the West are coopted by a
vision of the world that inexorably
leads to socialism and thereby to
Poverty
unfortunately in
decades motivated by some well-meaning
individuals willing to help others and
others motivated by the wish to belong
to a privileged cast the main leaders of
the western world have abandoned the
model of Freedom four different versions
of what we call collectivism we're here
to tell you that collectivist
experiments are never the solution to
the problems that afflict the citizens
of the world rather they are the root
cause do believe me no one better place
than us argentines to testify to these
two
points great stuff great stuff I don't
really agree with this guy on everything
because well you heard the way he speaks
he's a Libertarian so he's speaking
about material Goods about about how to
alleviate poverty how to enrich people
he's speaking about freedom in a liberal
lowercase L sense so he contrasts that
with collectivism and as I've said on
the show many times I think radical
individualism and radical collectivism I
think they're just two sides of the same
coin and they're both opposed to the
common good and tradition and
conservatism and so I I can't say three
cheers for Javier mle but I can say two
cheers for Javier mle because these guys
need to hear it these World economic
Forum people do want to Pedal socialism
they look to China as the model they
some of them are outright Communists
they're dancing around with witches
they're they're opposed to Freedom both
the defective libertarian view of
freedom and the true classical view of
Freedom look they're opposed to both of
it and so it's great it's it's amazing
to see a world leader show up and give
them a piece of his mind and at least
point out all the stuff they're getting
wrong even if if Malay doesn't have the
total right answer to combat it really
really great glad to see it in other
wise alternately bizarre and uh
downright occult kind of world economic
Forum the big topic of we this year
concerns America and it concerns the
Republican party and it concerns
president koffe they are terrified and
they've said this openly of the return
of Donald Trump so they're going to do
whatever they can to subvert Donald
Trump they know that Trump is popular
they know he's the most popular guy in
the GOP they know he's the most popular
guy in the presidential race he's out
polling Biden right now so what are they
going to do they're going to try to
prevent people from even having the
opportunity to elect him they're going
to try to undermine his campaign before
people can cast a ballot and they're
doing that by Prosecuting him so one of
the big cases against Trump forget about
Biden's doj going after him with the
Jack Smith case over the classified
documents that Joe Biden mishandled as
well forget about that there's this case
in Fulton County in Georgia because they
say that the fact that the sitting
president of the United States called
the secretary of state of Georgia and
raised questions and doubts about the
legitimacy of the election that was
plagued by allegations of fraud because
of that the man is an insurrectionist
and he should be thrown in prison
they're they're running a RICO case
against him Rico is for racketeering
it's it's the type of prosecution used
against the
mafia they're trying this totally I mean
any prosecution of a former president
current leader of the opposition totally
unprecedented but especially to pretend
that that you're a mobster just because
you're in the oppos opposing political
party totally crazy well it looks like
the corruption runs even deeper in that
Georgia prosecution
because Fanny Willis the da in Fulton
County has been caught in a major
Scandal Financial political even
romantic the prosecutor that the da who
brought the charges against Trump that
she picked appears to be her lover who
she paid a lot of money to taxpayer
dollars and then that lover appears to
have taken her on very lavish vacations
and met with the Biden Administration
and the whole thing stinks to high
heaven so the allegations come up
they're being reported even in left-wing
papers what does fanny Willis say does
she deny it does she say this is
completely ridiculous does she say this
is a Witch
Hunt no she plays the race card at a
church on Sunday but dear God are you
listening why does commissioner Thorne
and so many others question my decision
in a special
counsel Lord your flawed hard-headed and
imperfect child I'm a little
confused I appointed Three Special
counsel as is my right to do paid them
all the same hourly rate they only
attacked
one I hired one white woman a good
personal friend and great
lawyer a superstar I tell you I hired
one white man brilliant my friend and a
great
lawyer and I hired one black man another
Superstar a great
friend and a great
lawyer yeah but the white lady didn't
take you on expensive vacations to the
Caribbean with the money that you paid
her she says that she paid them the same
hourly rate other Outlets are reporting
that that isn't true that she actually
paid this this special friend of hers a
lot more money uh but I think the
evidence that she's guilty is one
neither She nor the prosecutor have
denied the affair and two she didn't go
to the media to talk about this she
didn't hold a press conference she shows
up to a black church to say dear lord
they're going after me cuz I'm a black
woman she played that race card as fast
as she could that is the last Refuge of
Scoundrels they have got this woman dead
to rights and it's not just me a right
winger saying this even the leftwing
papers are saying it probably the most
devastating reporting on this so far has
actually come from The Washington Post
we'll get to that in one second we will
talk about it but first we got to talk
about pure talk right now go to Pur
talk.com if you're like me there's none
a day goes by you don't call or text
someone that you care about I sometimes
I'm a a little weak on the texting but
usually there's one or two people in at
least my wife you know what kind of text
my friends at peer talk are making that
easier and more affordable to connect
with the most important people in your
life peer talk gives you phenomenal
coverage on America's Most Dependable 5G
Network it's the same coverage you know
and love but for half the price of the
other guys with unlimited plans starting
at just 20 bucks a month the average
family saves almost $1,000 a year as a
veteran owned company Pure Talk raised
$10 million toward veterans debt last
year alone what's more Pure Talk
customer service team is located right
here in the good old us OFA as far as
I'm concerned that's worth switching
over just for that they can help you
make the switch in as little as 10
minutes so I challenge you to stand with
a company that Champions your beliefs
today go to Pur talk.com kwes right now
you will save an additional 50% off your
first month that is Pur talk.com klees
to save on wireless with a company you
can be proud to spend your money with I
really really like these guys they've
got a phenomenal service I've got it
here somewhere in my home right now I've
got that phone Pur
talk.com headline in the Washington Post
you know that far right-wing paper
Washington Post Nathan Wade embattled
prosecutor in Georgia Trump case has
little prosecution
experience not only did this woman pick
her alleged lover to to prosecute this
huge case against the former president
current leader of the opposition but she
picked a guy who is completely
unqualified to do it it was just so blat
it was so Brazen how did she think she
would get away with
this so ridiculous that even the
Washington Post has to call it out they
write quote in the fall of 2021 Nathan
Wade the prosecutor had little
experience Prosecuting criminal cases in
the Atlanta area serving as a municipal
judge who mostly dealt with traffic
tickets and running a private practice
that focuses on family law and contract
disputes then fton County DA Fanny
Willis tapped him to lead the biggest
case of her career one of Trump's
codefendants alleged an Court filing
last week that the two prosecutors are
lovers who have vacation together on
Wade's dime that he got from the
taxpayers in Napa Valley and the
Caribbean the accusations if true could
present a conflict of interest or could
amount to fraud you don't say and then
wapo concludes the episode has drawn
attention to an arrangement in which
Willis's office hired an outside
attorney and paid his firm more than
$650,000 over two years to lead a
criminal investigation typically managed
by civil servants great Point Washington
Post never thought I'd say that great
point
why is an outside lawyer even handling
this why isn't the the DA's office doing
it
internally well because then there's not
as much opportunity for graft and
kickbacks that's
why they go to the Caribbean they go to
Napa Valley you know where else the
prosecutor goes the prosecutor goes and
meets with Biden
officials so these this investigation
and this prosecution in Georgia it's
supposed to be totally separate from the
Biden White House this isn't Joe Biden
just Prosecuting his popular political
rival because he wants to take him out
of the race no no it's
separate well if it's separate then why
is the prosecutor meeting for hours on
end with Biden Lackey and then here's
the best part the cherry on the Sunday
he bills fton County for the time he
build them something like $8,000 it was
at least four it might have been
$8,000 whatever it was thousands of
dollars for the time as if to say yeah
I'm here I'm working for Fulton County
and we're taking our marching orders
from Biden who wants to lock his
opponent in prison because he's not
going to win the election fair and
square so people are are really shocked
by this I'm not shocked by this these
are people who would for the first time
in American history throw the leader of
the opposition the major rival candidate
for president in
prison on completely trumped up charges
pun intended of course they're corrupt
of course they're cheating on their
spouses and taking handouts and giving
Kickbacks and going on vacation to the
Caribbean and meeting with the crooks in
DC to try to coordinate the prosecu of
course man of course they are people are
not usually just a little bit
corrupt okay and what what the Democrats
broadly are doing to Trump right now is
the height of American political
corruption yeah and and look this might
they might have flown a little too close
to the Sun here this might spoil that
whole case that's why the Democrats have
backups that's why they're going after
him in New York and they're going after
him in Washington DC and I don't know
pretty soon they're going to go after
him in pville because they know that
individually all of these cases are
frivolous they're they're so ridiculous
and they need backups because this one
very well might have fallen apart when
the libs lose the Washington Post you
know they're in trouble now for his part
Trump is feeling pretty good the GOP
Primary is effectively over DeSantis and
Haley are still in the race official I
think Casa Hutchinson might still
officially be in the race but there's
really no path to victory for anyone
other than Trump right now uh so the
party is consolidating behind him
including the clearest sign of this
yet Senator Ted Cruz president Trump's
Chief rival in 2016 the man who almost
beat Trump for the
nomination just came out and endorsed
him listen last night was decisive it
was it was a Domin victory for Donald
Trump I I got to say there's no place
like the Iowa caucuses I know it
intimately the men and women of Iowa
they take their responsibility
incredibly seriously they scrutinize the
candidates it's an amazing process and
I'm a big believer in letting democracy
play out well last night it played out
and I I got to say Trump's victory was
across the board he won 51% of the vote
he won 98 of the counties
congratulations to president Trump on
that dominating Victory and and at this
point I I believe this race is over so
so I am proud to endorse Donald Trump
for president of the United States I
look forward to supporting him
enthusiastically because I think it's
time for the Republican party to unite
for us to come together we've got to
beat Joe Biden we've got to beat this
disastrous cultural Marxist agenda in
the White House we've got to retake the
United States Senate we've got to hold
the house we got to come together and
win and with the results last night the
people have spoken it's time to move
onward to victory in November I think
Senator Cruz handled this very
well the guy ran a brutal campaign
against Trump in
2016 then when Trump won Cruz got on
board they accomplished some great
things together they worked very well
together when Trump was President then
when this primary came up Senator Cruz
stayed out of it he just he didn't run
for president again
he basically stayed out of of the
primary perhaps in part because some of
his former political team were working
for other candidates and so I felt it
was a classy move he stayed out of it
and now it is very clear the race is for
all intents and purposes over it it
really doesn't need to drag out any
longer than it has I'm not calling on
the other candidates to drop out they
can stay in as long as they like but it
seems very unlikely that there is
anything else to be gained from these
other candidates staying in the race and
so Cruz said okay all right there it is
whether love Trump whether you hate
Trump he's the guy he's the nominee and
we all want to beat Joe Biden and he is
per not only acceptable I think to
basically the whole GOP but some people
are very enthusiastic about him being
the nominee so however you feel about
him personally let's get together and
let's support the nominee very classy
very mature way to handle it and a big
sign that the primary is over Trump got
another endorsement on top of Senator
Cruz and some of the other top
Republicans who have who have jumped on
board and that would be Meek
Mill I don't really know Meek Mill you
know I'm not the hippest cat out there
necessarily but me Meek Mill is a
rapper and he tweeted out in response to
a rally that V and Trump were doing
together he tweeted out he said wait
till y all see who the black people in
poverty voting for four exclamation
points now what does that mean it was
being reported
as an implicit endorsement of trump I
didn't know I couldn't quite tell how to
read it but then I realized two days
ago he made his political views even
clearer he said Joe Biden is too old to
be our president respectfully WTF is
going on in the American system that
yall pushing this through like it's okay
to trust what we
seeing so it's pretty clear here Meek
Mill Mr Mill endorsing Donald Trump and
my pal Nate Hawkman pointed something
out yest yesterday as well which is a
ton of black rappers have endorsed
Trump conspicuously the most famous
white rapper hates Trump and constantly
whines about it Eminem but a bunch of
other rappers Kodak Black Lil pump Kanye
of course Lil Wayne Ice Cube now Meek
Mill have all endorsed Trump at some
point over the last 8 to 10
years that's kind of weird right Trump I
think is the first Republican candidate
for any office that any rappers have
publicly endorsed what gives what's
going on here man I'll tell you what's
going on you know that I like to read
political philosophy I like to read all
the greats cisero Aristotle dooso Cortez
Edmund Burke and of course Mars m a
rzz a brilliant political philosopher
who want observed real recognize
real that's what's going on
here Donald Trump is basically a
rapper Donald Trump is a tabloid hitting
wild outrageous flashy paints everything
in Gold International Celebrity who
dates supermodels and is outrageous he's
been that guy for 40 years he's appeared
in rap songs in public big hit rap songs
something like 300 times or
more and to quote
Mars real recognize real you think that
rappers you think that wild entertainers
of any sort are going to be endorsing
Mitt Romney not very many you get the
occasional Clint Eastwood but that's
about
it Trump it's a little bit different so
I know people look at him they say he's
going to lose all these voters he turns
people off he says says nasty things he
he zigs and zags on policy I know I'm
not denying any of that stuff but I am
really skeptical of the claim that Trump
shrinks the party I just don't think
it's true I don't think it was true in
2016 and I and I believe that my take on
that was proven when he won the election
I don't I think it's true now he's he's
got the traditionalists the rad trads
the people willing to wield government
power and the extreme Libertarians both
endorsing him Compact magazine the
American post Al on one hand and Rand
Paul and Mike Lee on the other and
they're coming
together even some of the foreign policy
Hawks like him Donald Trump ironically
has has been able to unify the
conservative movement the three-legged
stool of Ronald Reagan the Trad
conservatives the Libertarians and the
foreign policy Hawks he's been able to
bring them together better than any
Republican since Ronald Reagan for all
of his
divisiveness the guy is weirdly a uniter
there no question we're living in a
clown world that very statement that I
just said it it shows you what a crazy
world we're living in the powers that be
are straight out of a carnival basic
Notions of right and wrong Justice truth
even reality itself have been thrown out
the window the world is coming to an end
how are we going to make sense of it
join Jonathan Pou in the new four-part
series end of the world as he explains
why the world as we know it is ending
how to survive it and how we can plant
the seeds for the next world today
Jonathan peo is an icon Carver public
speaker YouTuber and a good friend of
Jordan Peterson you might remember
Jonathan from his profoundly
Illuminating comments in Jordan's series
on Exodus now he's back and will draw
upon his deep knowledge of Christian
tradition stories mythology and history
to explain the contradictions in our
society wacky phenomena and how this
pattern will reach its conclusion in end
of the world you will receive a
thoughtful framework to make sense of
these confusing times and a road map to
lead us out of the clown world and
restore order all episodes are available
now exlic ly on dailywire plus if you
have not become a member this is the
perfect time go to dailywire.com
subscribe unmask the Carneys and see
beyond the end watch end of the world
today speaking of real recognize
real I don't want to brag but I just
received a major
honor this comes by way of
fire very well-known organization
freedom of uh individual rights in
education they have a list of all the
cancelled speakers this year on the
right and on the left they're virtually
all right-wingers canceled by the left
but they got a list and it turns
out I am the
champion disinvite of 2023 I was
cancelled I was disinvited from campus
speaking engagements more than anyone
else in 2023 and I consider that a great
honor I lost a lot of opportunities to
get my views out there I lost money I
lost a really important part of what I
do which is to
but I I gained a lot I gained the
greatest amount of ir from the left and
I take that as as a great badge uh some
of my fellow contestants most of these
guys are actually personal friends of
mine I think Matt and Charlie Kirk but
came in second I think uh ilas Shapiro
those guys had and maybe Riley Gaines
too they had two
cancellations
each I think maybe Riley only had one no
Riley had two and uh there there were
some other shout outs there as well
James Lindsay got cancelled there were a
number of them I'm really honored I'm
especially honored because I didn't even
state publicly all of the cancellations
they credit me here with three I was
actually cancelled from more
like five or six schools and I I haven't
said it publicly because I don't want to
just whine all the time believe it or
not about uh these kind of personal SLS
but also because we might be able to
beat the liberal administrations and end
up this semester on those campuses so
we're going to play it cool in any case
though thank you to fire thank you to
the leftist administrators at the
universities thank you first to the
conservative students for inviting me
thank you to the leftist administrators
for cancelling me in this ridiculous way
because I have the audacity to say crazy
things like men are not women and
there's objective truth and stuff like
that and uh for all of my fellow
contestants I look forward to sharing a
bowl of GRL with all of you in the goog
probably sooner rather than later if
things keep going the way that they are
I also want to thank Steve Maguire who's
a fellow at the American Council of
trustees and alumni for pointing out my
uh dubious distinction speaking of free
speech rup
Paul who I don't really know like I know
the face and I know the name I don't
really know what that person does other
than pop up on TV and say outrageous
things every now and again rup Paul has
just come out and
said that that everyone needs to cool it
with the around drag queen Story
Hour listen if a drag queen wants to
read you a story at a library listen to
her
because knowledge is power and if
someone tries to restrict your access to
power they are trying to scare you so
listen to a drag queen we love you thank
you listen to a drag queen knowledge is
power really interesting point rup Paul
now do Bibles in schools what about that
if a teacher wants to read you a Bible
in a school you should let her right you
should listen to her oh no no no we
can't do that no no no that's terrible
that's unconstitutional that's evil
that's oppressive that's terrible don't
ever let anyone do that
ever if a conservative student group
wants to host a totally mainstream
right-wing public figure you should go
listen to that person right no no we
have to shut them down that's terrible
because knowledge is power that's the
one point that that guy made that's
true know is power and the dissemination
of knowledge is power information is
power this term misinformation has
become very popular these days but it's
a silly term I'm not the first to
observe
it there's just
information there are information Wars
that go on and uh what sort of
information is allowed to get out there
what sort of information is publicly
encouraged how that information gets out
there what kind of information gets
Amplified that's going to determine the
Contours of the standards and Norms of
your Society it's going to it's going to
determine how people perceive the world
and how they behave and what kind of
country that you live in that's what
that's about what rup Paul and all the
rest of the the pro pro drag people are
saying is not we want Total Free Speech
they obviously don't look at the list
put out by
fire what they want is their subversive
false ugly Wicked voices to be heard and
to set the Contours of society and they
want to suppress voices that are
traditional Common Sense true good
beautiful any anything like that that
they've got to keep out this is
why a lot of this craziness on campus
began almost immediately after liberal
activists on the courts banned the Bible
in prayer from
schools because nature abor a vacuum so
once you once you take the truth and the
good and the good stuff and the kind of
information that buildt our whole
civilization when you take that out of
schools there's a vacuum and what's
going to fill that is going to be less
good and less beautiful and less true
especially then when the schools uh
double down on all of it and create
incentives for more of it and special
protections for it and the popular
culture encourages it as
well so now we've
got
time
now speaking of hostility toward good
and true
beliefs you know I'm not a huge football
guy believe it or not I was not the
captain of my high school or college
football team but I saw a clip going
around of a guy on the Texas football
team whatever that is which one is it I
don't know but he's got a thing on it
says Texans this guy his name is CJ
Stroud a hug Houston he's the
quarterback for Houston and
anyway what I'm really interested in in
this story is who he
thanked after winning a
game and then what I'm especially
interested in is what part of the
interview NBC cut out which we'll get to
in one second first though my favorite
comment yesterday is from good bones
1289 who says I can't believe Haley
outlasted vake honestly I don't believe
she really did I do I totally do she'll
probably Outlast to
santis not because she's the strongest
candidate in the race not because she's
the most likely candidate to be the
nominee of course not the is super smart
he did incredibly well he went from 0%
name recognition to something like 8% in
the polls that's very very impressive
and Dan santis is great too I really
like Dan
santis but as I said from the beginning
the problem for de santis was he had no
Lane he he was a trumpy candidate
who whose initial pitch at least was I'm
Trump without the baggage but the race
forced him to be in the anti-trump lane
but he's not really a never Trumper type
he's kind of trumpy so he had there was
no no Lane he had to be kind of trumpy
and then Trump was going to beat him
because Trump is Trump same thing with v
v and Trump disagree on very little V
explicitly ran his campaign as America
first as carrying on the torch of
Trump's Legacy but Trump doesn't want to
give up the linelight yet so he was
never going to make it all that far I
mean that was just built into the
calculus of the campaign the only the
only candidate who really will have a
lane even As Trump continues to win is
going to be Haley who styled herself as
the anti-trump and she's really leaned
into that lane so I'm not surprised I
don't I don't think it's a knock on V I
don't think it's a knock on to santis
but you got to play your part when you
get cast in the play you cast in the
movie you know you got to play your part
or you're not going to you're not going
to stay very long on that
stage Houston quarterback CJ
Stroud won a game and he thanked Jesus
and NBC News didn't seem to like that
what does this moment mean first
foremost I just want to give all glory
and praise to my Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ I mean it's been amazing what
does this moment mean I mean it's been
amazing being in this city for as short
as I've been but the love that I've got
oh wait hold on that was the supposed to
be the same clip one was how it actually
went and then the other one was how they
posted it how they edited it and posted
and they did you see they cut out
something kind of
important weird huh is that weird that
the media would cut out the actual heart
of this man's message which is I want to
thank my Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
can't say that it's kind of weird we're
a Christian country country we're
Christian
civilization not only is that a good and
true thing for him to say but it would
be very very
popular and yet the media cut it
out weird isn't
it it's so weird how Christianity
continues to be as it has been since the
Advent of our Lord and savior the most
persecuted religion ever in the in the
whole history of the world is that kind
of weird it's almost as if we wrel not
against flesh as they do in the football
game but against principalities and
powers and spiritual wickedness in high
places in any case maybe I got to tune
into football because this guy CJ strad
he's got his head screwed on straight
even if not a single person at NBC seems
to speaking of
football the New England new head coach
has just come out and made clear the Dei
policies for the team I do see color
because I believe if you don't see color
you can't see racism and whatever
whatever happens black white disabled
person I've always even someone with
disabilities I always uh you know for
the most part people are like you know
don't you know when they're young they
they kind of make the spot hot younger
people know what that means but what I
would say is like no I want you to be
able to go up to those people and really
understand those people so it goes back
to whatever is black white yellow it
really doesn't matter but it does matter
so we can try to fix a problem that we
all know we have it really doesn't
matter but it does matter that's the
kind of high high level discourse I
would expect from apparently a leftist
now in the position of coaching the New
England
Patriots I don't see I see I see color I
see color because we got to fix the
racism the racism in
football yeah finally finally the black
man is going to have a fair Shake in the
National Football League you know it's
been a long time coming but I am so
relieved that finally we're going to see
a black guy playing football you know
isn't that great wow the Civil Rights
Movement is finally flourishing we're
going to get our if if you wanted to see
color to stop the uh racial inequality
in football you would have to introduce
the first White player into football
that's not fair there are some obviously
there was uh the former quarterback for
this very team what's that guy Brady he
was pretty popular and uh let me think
of another white football player there's
the guy who's dating Taylor
Swift and um and that's it I think I
think that's pretty much all of
it white people the lone white
people
I don't even really disagree with this
guy in principle if his premises were
true that there were some awful racism
then he's right the only way to rectify
that problem would be to be conscious of
Race To not to not deny that people have
racial
differences what I think he's missing
what all of the libs miss when they
envey against the evil white man the
source of all the problems in the world
we are told is
that white people people are the only
people who do not see color in as much
as that phrase means anything at all I
don't see color I don't the only people
for whom that is true is white
people the only people for whom that has
been true ever in the whole history of
the world is white people this is very
clear from Modern social
science when when you ask people their
racial
Consciousness when when you ask people
hey is is race is your race somewhat or
very important to you every racial group
other than white people is above
50% Asians Hispanics for black people
it's above
70% what's the number for white people
15 white people have zero racial
Consciousness 15% I guess they don't
they really don't see color everyone
else does and everyone else has for all
of history which is how we've ended up
in a situation today where white people
are the only group that you can
discriminate against by law and
according to the Moray of
society you can also discriminate
against the Asians by law but it's still
socially unacceptable to criticize them
or to insult them white people are the
only group that you can legally
discriminate against in college
admissions for instance even after the
overturning of affirmative action all
the schools came out and said don't
worry we'll work around this we're still
going to discriminate against whitey in
the admissions but they're also the only
group that you are encouraged to
discriminate against the only group that
that you are taught in school and in the
media and in Hollywood and just
everywhere the only group that we were
told is is the cause of all the problems
in the world everyone's going to attack
this guy for this view this is the view
that most people hold ironically white
people don't really hold that view now
speaking of liberal white
people hold hold on to your seats if
you're driving pull over this one's
going to shock you the president pres of
an
lgbtq Pride organization in Canada has
been arrested for child sex
crimes stop the presses hat tip to Libs
of Tik Tock for pointing this out uh the
guy's name is Shawn grel he is an
outspoken LGBT activist head of a pride
organization in Canada arrested for not
not only for uh possessing and
distributing child pornography but for
sex crimes against children really
really awful heinous sort of
stuff it's always the ones you most
expect it's it's not totally fair it is
sometimes people that you don't expect
the the counter example I can hear it
now all the libs responding to this clip
that inevitably will be broken up by
Media Matters they'll say what about the
Catholic priests and there there was a
major sex scandal especially at the turn
of the Millennium uh
among Catholic priests that's
true now the Catholics were not unique
in this regard that the the level of
sexual uh disorder and and criminality
that they found among Catholic priests
it it wasn't particular to that religion
it's true it's it's about the same rate
as every other religious group out there
it's actually considerably lower than
certain other religious groups
especially non-Christian religious
groups uh but it's
also much much lower than sex abuse
among Public School teachers much much
lower the public school teachers it's
multiples higher than the Catholic
priests
but usually it's the ones you most
expect usually it's not the really nice
upstanding family guy who does what he's
supposed to do and leads an apparently
virtuous life usually it's like these
guys okay it's the guys who make their
whole identity weird sex stuff and who
run weird sex clubs and I guess my
question here
is why do we encourage this why do we
allow this to happen why are there weird
sex organizations all over the West
there didn't used to be now there are
and they hold big parades in the middle
of the street and they are permitted to
go to public libraries and elementary
schools and put on weird sex
performances specifically targeted
toward kids often involving actual child
molesters that have been convicted and
have been widely reported on why why do
we tolerate this the first amendment I
don't think the founding fathers were
into this stuff this this would not have
been tolerated until recent decades this
has no bearing on the First Amendment or
the American tradition why to what
end because some pervert wants to do it
I why I don't care what Shawn grael
wants to do about anything he's very
deviant and disordered and he he has no
right to do any of this stuff why do why
do we encourage it what's what's good
about it what good is to be gained from
it not very much we don't think in those
terms though anymore what's good like
basic stuff you know polies exist uh to
do more good stuff and less bad stuff
and so people can live a good life in a
flourishing Community how about we start
thinking that way because otherwise the
way that our political communities are
going to be ordered is when bad people
who like to do bad things go meet up and
plot out how to control world and invite
actual witches to guide them in doing
that that doesn't seem like a recipe for
Success I'm Michael NS this is the
Michael NS show see you
tomorrow